well I always loved working with
Scorsese because he he had the
confidence to know unlike a lot of
directors he had the confidence to know
exactly what he wanted and he said okay
you're the writer give me this and he
didn't fret over he just went off and
you know set up his shots and thought
you know he sort of trusted me you know
to deliver the goods a lot of guys are
like so anxious that they never know
what they want and you get caught in the
middle you get into power place between
actors and directors and you know you
fit you know you feel like a secretary
with a dog collar on but I never I you
know would score say see you know it was
like he just knew exactly what he wanted
and you know it was a breeze I mean not
it's never easy but it was relatively it
was a breeze other people I worked with
that I really liked is David Simon and
the crew around the wire the only reason
to do that show other than we sure don't
do it for the money I mean you open up
the envelope and you know moths fly out
but um you do it because it's the wire
and it was it seemed like a like a group
of peers well although it wasn't cuz
Simon was to create a ian had burns you
know they were the writer producer
creator is always the guy that rewrites
everything and is in control but given
that there was none of the games it was
me and pelicano pelicanos and Lehane and
and EDD Byrnes and David Simon and I
felt like when we're all together you
know there was there was a sobriety you
know of purpose and and a mutual
sympathy and respect you know for each
other's work that I really find in in
group situations like moviemaking and it
was just a great showing although I
frankly it was so high I didn't even
understand my own scripts most of the
time but you know I did you know I did
what I was told you know and then some
and I was just really proud to be part
of that